if you received a mysterious text
message this week from someone
unexpected you were not alone this
happened to a lot of people yesterday
they reported they received messages
that appear to have originally been sent
on or around Valentine's Day this year
these people never received a text
message isn't in the first place the
delay text created some awkward moments
one person tweeted got a text last night
from a girl I almost dated back in
February I was really confused until I
realized that the text was also sent
back in February that's Dan it said yes
I'd love to go out for Valentine's Day
now I know why we never dated
because he never got it Oh another
tweeted this so at 2:30 this morning my
phone decided to send a text to my
ex-girlfriend from nine months ago she
made this really sweet video of us for
Valentine's Day she thought I didn't
respond so that led to among other
things a ruined holiday so you know
that's how today's girl that's from
buffets
sprint said wow there was a little
maintenance error t-mobile blamed a
third-party vendor but I was thinking
suppose you had broken up with the
person suppose the person is no longer
here it could make a whole life changing
yes that's up it could be